no sounds like a bloodhound is next to
me we're here trying weird dessert
combinations from the internet
I'm worried yeah I got no idea what's
coming down the pipe I'm a little
worried that there's spit buckets to our
left but yeah a little nervous I'll try
anything once
I used to dip my chicken nuggets in
chocolate pudding so I'll do anything to
it ready to it hmm
I love chocolate ice cream any kind of
wasabi like goes right to my brain stem
and it like kills me you're gonna be
done laughs I told you I don't like
zombie and now you're trying to kill me
how do you feel about something I do
nothing I have to do like a little bit
I'm a wuss when it comes to spice can
you squeeze a little squeeze on top okay
all right I did it's not coming out I
can't do it No okay okay I'm gonna chase
this it's really spicy though yeah I
think I'm a fan if it was on vanilla ice
cream I think I might like it more all
right I like it more than the chocolate
but I don't necessarily like it this is
the type of thing that I would
definitely finish to have finished it
often times when you're at a Japanese
restaurant they end your meal with a
complimentary ice cream since you're
eating at a Japanese restaurant there's
likely to be wasabi and as a joke your
friends like dude I dare you to put some
silver in your screams this may or may
not have been a personal experience and
I'm gonna go thumbs down oh yeah
churros and something salty guessing
that that is mayonnaise yes churros and
sour cream I like sour cream and I like
churros all right open minds you first
I'm gonna get a good old dollop oh crap
whoa that's pretty good
yeah I'm gonna go back in again if he
was a little disappointing to me it's
not what I would want out of my dip it's
like when you put um like a cream cheese
like frosting on a toaster guys you know
what the sour cream does to the churro
it masks the over sweetness and then it
provides like a nice cold whip so that
the contrast between the hot and cold is
really nice I would 100% be into this I
got a party that's a heart like a
proofed split decision what is it is
this coffee or balsamic vinegar I
believe it's soy sauce Oh
soy sauce and ice cream you think I
haven't done this might taste better
before a lot it looks good I definitely
prefer ice cream to soy sauce and I
don't think I come together salt and
sweet is a thing this could be really
good I'm having a stroke but it smells
good cheers okay I kind of like this
actually
mmm you like it mm-hmm it feels like I
had to like separate bites of two
different meals it's like a salted
caramel almost exactly what it tastes
yeah it feels like like it could be
blended together with like one more
taste I don't know what taste that would
be though if you go somewhere and they
put soy sauce on your ice cream it's
gonna be like ten bucks it seems I can
have a thing to do there's the salt
there's the sweet they go together just
maybe not this salt or this sweet if
someone were to offer this to me again I
would definitely have to pass on it I
would definitely accept it very good
host
whoa I'm a hard down over here I'll go a
little higher than wasn't bad no it's
not good I'm not gonna be scarred the
pairings were in the realm of like human
food yeah and I would argue that it was
actually pretty good though I think my
overall dining
was highly positive if we had a ring
come for me the churro was the best
churros and sour cream number one yeah
churros sour cream for me I just
couldn't get get over the sour cream it
kind of dug the wasabi on the chocolate
ice cream - ice cream soy sauce an ice
cream number two vanilla ice cream with
the soy sauce I'll put the wasabi over
the salsa crazy and then the worst I'd
say was the wasabi chocolate ice cream
Bobby and yeah and then I would go with
sabe plus vanilla ice cream I would give
you a three stars on Yelp and I'd like
to speak with manager